[Musique]
l'alimentation n'est pas une marchandise
comme une autre il faut faire très
attention à ça
[Musique]
là où ça va pas c'est que peu pour
ramasser les fraises les abricots les
pêches et les pommes et les poires et
cetera on ait recours quasi
exclusivement je pense à la france 1 à
de la main d'oeuvre étrangère
ce sacre est une très grande dépendance
d'ondés qui est un accident du type
locaux vides et bien les travailleurs ne
viennent plus et on a perdu des milliers
sinon des centaines de milliers de
tonnes de produits frais fruits et
légumes à cause de ça
[Musique]
vous avez vu ce qu'on a fait aux états
unis en france aussi en europe on a jeté
des milliers de litres de lait etc
ça fait mal au coeur évidemment c'est
insupportable du point de vue de morale
[Musique]
si vous êtes en asie vous avez besoin de
riz pour survivre si vous êtes en europe
ou en amérique vous avez besoin de blé
et de maïs
donc ce ça ce sont des produits
absolument indispensables à la vie et il
est préférable d'essayer de les produire
sur son sol dans son pays que de les
importer
[Musique]
maintenant on atteint des limites en
2020 et les agronomes le reconnaissent
les sols sont épuisés
on a dégradé les terres on a pollué les
nappes phréatiques et c'est donc il faut
aller vers un système que l'on pourrait
qualifier de plus autonome et plus
économes
[Musique]
ayant comme objectif l'autonomie
alimentaire régionale autant que faire
se peut
la nourriture est bien c'est un bien
commun de l'humanité
alors évidemment il faut le conserver
dans des règles économiques aussi il
faut que les marchés soient là et cetera
mais complétons les marchés en mettant
sur le même pied
le profit économique la protection de
l'environnement et surtout l'équité
sociale les droits humains
[Musique]